la convivencia es lo que la asociación
coexiste coexistir en español vino a
enseñar a los estudiantes de esta
escuela católica
la gente se sorprendió de que yo una
judía defendiera a los musulmanes y me
sorprendí de que ellos se sorprendieron
intervienen en las escuelas para hablar
de religiones y de construir prejuicios
sin ningún tabú el objetivo es formar a
los futuros ciudadanos para que vivan en
la sociedad
finalmente la laicidad permite que cada
persona exprese libremente sus
convicciones con respecto a la ley a los
demás sin embargo la república laica se
mantiene firme contra las tendencias
fundamentalistas contrarias a la ley y
también contra los que llaman al odio a
las religiones y a los creyentes
durante dos horas los estudiantes
interactúan y hacen preguntas nos enseñó
mucho sobre la tolerancia sobre cómo
interactuar con otras personas
establecer un diálogo en torno a las
religiones una apuesta exitosa la
profesora que trajo la asociación aquí
lo acoge con agrado somos una escuela
católica también tenemos estudiantes
musulmanes y están muy preocupados por
su lugar en la sociedad especialmente
con los recientes acontecimientos y se
sintieron aliviados al ver que el
diálogo es posible el entendimiento es
posible
algunos acuden a la asociación de no
siempre abordar las cuestiones más
espinosas pero su presidenta los
contradice cuando a menudo se nos
reprocha a nuestro lado cariño citó
nuestra ingenuidad pero estoy
profundamente convencida de que nuestro
modelo es el más activista y el más
difícil precisamente porque debemos ser
muy atentos a cada palabra que usamos de
toxic o one watch y le dejamos este
pequeño pueblo de saint marc en
dirección a córdoba en los suburbios del
norte de parís
ese día la emoción aumenta entre los
estudiantes de la escuela secundaria a
causa de una visita inusual françois
hollande hizo el viaje para hablarles
sobre la laicidad primero son ciudadanos
franceses luego son musulmanes para los
que lo son y ustedes son ante todos
ciudadanos con todos los derechos y
libertades que conlleva la ciudadanía en
la asamblea hay muchos estudiantes
musulmanes los adolescentes no dudan en
hacerle preguntas que disponen al
ex-presidente libertad de expresión el
uso del velo discriminación me gustaría
hablar en nombre de todos los jóvenes
musulmanes de france nos sentimos bien
en francia no nos comparen con otros
hay extremistas por todas partes los
musulmanes estamos a gusto en francia en
una visita a varios establecimientos en
noviembre el ex jefe de estado señaló la
creciente falta de comprensión de los
jóvenes con respecto al laicismo
por eso el papel de los profesores es
transmitir lo que es la laicidad es
decir en primer lugar las leyes de
francia que nos permiten vivir juntos
las leyes de la república esta profesora
ha tratado de transmitirles durante años
frente a alumnos a veces reticentes
favorece el diálogo y la escucha
por ejemplo sobre la cuestión de yo soy
charlie es algo de lo que hemos hablado
mucho los estudiantes a menudo sienten
yo no soy charlie pero qué significa
charlie no hay ninguna palabra en el
diccionario no hay ninguna entrada en el
diccionario
yo soy charlie significa que apruebo lo
que hacen sí pero en un momento dado la
gente que se manifestó el 9 de enero
dijo yo soy charlie porque apoyo la
libertad de expresión la libertad de
expresión si lo apoyo fórmulas como yo
soy charlie los sobrevivientes del
periódico chat directo vienen a clase
nos reuniremos con ellos y con los
estudiantes hablamos de las famosas
caricaturas pero esta orden de ser
chardy no significa nada porque charly
no significa nada si charlie quiere
decir que me gustan los discos de char
liendo y voy a comprarlos entonces no
eres tan dick si se me malinterprete lo
que dije y entonces continuó con lo que
usted está diciendo aquí y si eso es lo
que estamos especificando no estoy ni a
favor de charlie ni a favor de los
atentados mantener el diálogo una
prioridad con los estudiantes que a
veces se encuentran en situaciones
sociales difíciles
hay para ustedes musulmanes de francia y
de algunos sectores una tensión entre
estos extremistas que les daría órdenes
de respetar más del islam hay una
presión que se hace en este sentido allí
en la vida real siempre hay hermanos
musulmanes del vecindario que vienen y
hablan contigo durante horas pero nunca
han predicado la violencia de personas
personas que honestamente el respeto
pero solo quiero decirles algo la
religión es algo personal y no es asunto
de nadie más
entre septiembre de 2019 y marzo de 2020
el sistema educativo nacional francés el
registro 935 denuncias de violaciones de
la laicidad por 12 millones y medio de
alumnos en francia es una cifra estable
según el observatorio de la laicidad que
sin embargo denuncia la falta de
formación de los profesores para este
politólogo los sucesivos gobiernos
tienen una gran responsabilidad en esta
situación a veces explosiva
brad jackson a veces de jugar
la reacción que debieron tener fue
enseñar la historia política que
permitió que estos niños estuvieran allí
la historia de nuestro colonialismo fue
muy mala y aún no se ha enseñado
suficiente y si no tiene un lugar en la
historia del país qué tipo de hogar te
quedas solo la religión diría que la
institución al no enseñar historia
política tomó la decisión de inscribir a
sus hijos en una casa religiosa enseñar
la laicidad y asegurar que sus
principios se respeten en la escuela el
desafío es grande como dicen los
profesores los problemas que tienen que
afrontar van mucho más allá del hecho
religioso en un contexto de crisis
económica y social que sigue empeorando